did i had the funniest idea for a year
in review here are some of the best
moments on my channel this year and it's
just all my brand deals
this video is sponsored by i got to take
a quick break to thank the sponsor of
this video just want to take a quick
break to thank the sponsor of today's
video guys you already know what honey
is listen finances it's the number one
shopping tool in america you need to
protect yourself online that
automatically the solution is a bunch of
right knowledge
it's either that or i'm gonna make just
like a fake
like reacting to like those car washing
videos dude this car washing is insane
yes 17-minute detail video and you're
like
[Music]
ever since i did the like 4k bong rip
for that one random ass vlog i've just
always wanted to take a chance and do
like a one-hour upload where i say
nothing yeah and i just watch bong rips
and then occasionally i might go
damn i'm sick and just see if anyone
goes all the way through maybe i'll do
some mr b [ __ ] remember i couldn't think
of anything this week so i'm gonna watch
three hours of 4k bong rips
i used to do that [ __ ] yeah you're like
counting to one million
like five days yeah
all right let's see this thing rip all
right is the back plate on it's
on all right can you reverse
oh dude that's so sick
i can't see [ __ ] back here i'm stuck
sick well that was fun i want to just
boot it so hard
bring over here
hey if this thing was fast enough i'd do
a burnout on that duke on that [ __ ]
duke scarf i have a such a burning
desire to just destroy that thing yeah
right now i kind of don't blame you just
boot it would be really funny to do that
to a child
give them an rc card they're like in the
house and you just come running down the
hallway and just like boom their first
acceleration yeah first time and they're
like they feel the
oh my
don't do don't
all right well that was fun yeah dude
free me free me free my boy from my boy
he didn't do nothing okay we should talk
probably i mean we've been talking
we should probably say something we will
say something just take a swig of that
maple syrup
okay
dude it's got one of these like george
washington like
like you know oh yeah old ass wax thing
yeah it feels whiskey man i'd
yeah while i did this shop i don't mind
freeing my race car no don't free it
cause they'll just drive it no no no
just freezing i'm gonna be forced to
boot it no i'm i'm just gonna drive i'm
gonna kick the thing it just he just
needs to come home okay all right all
right that's it that's all i need
i can't i really can't get this
oh here we go they got a little uh
nipple over here oh [ __ ] i just stepped
the [ __ ] underneath my [ __ ] are you
all right
no i'm good damn
let's just listen to this anyways that
[ __ ] stabbed me pretty good i'm not
gonna lie
i'm gonna pass out
is this this is the last episode of the
year yeah stop driving the [ __ ] thing
around i'm just driving him home
he's just coming back to daddy it's been
a year um what are you gonna name it
um
max verstappen
[Laughter]
no louie
named louie yeah okay it's been a year
we've had some crazy moments this year
yeah we met terry carnation
yep we had a chance to have meat canyon
on the show we let one of our clones out
i think next year we should let more
clones out yes hundred percent and she
lit we should a lot more clones out yeah
we did
a couple moment house shows this year
which were [ __ ] crazy yeah
uh yep really stepped it up on the the
ship's production
we're reflecting now yeah we are yeah
okay i like that let's give thanks
actually
thanks to all of you thanks to all of
you guys yeah no the the crew here i
mean that as well
and to the audience i was thinking the
audience first because like without them
none of us have a job uh that's a good
point okay thank you guys so much
[Laughter]
thanks for listening to the show or
whatever the [ __ ] yeah oh my god you
guys are on top of my spotify rapt oh my
god
[Laughter]
no i'm kidding thank you guys
that's seriously so interesting
i'm joking thank you for real damn you
know thank you thanks audience thanks to
the crew here for making the show great
yeah it's it's been a hell of a year the
crew has grown a lot yes it's been a
time yeah we're a real ass company now
yeah we had a [ __ ] christmas party
yeah we did that's when you know yeah we
had a sign in everything it said tmg
productions yeah
we went bowling
yeah it was sick yeah it was [ __ ]
awesome luke suggested we start a
bowling league and i think we're gonna
do that you just see randomly a two and
a half hour upload of bowling yeah
that's why unedited yes
raw yeah
one camera angle yes it's gonna be like
those channels that upload marble races
but not even produced as well yeah and
actually we're gonna we're gonna verse
other podcasts yeah that's the plan is
we want to verse other podcasts so if
you're a podcast host
or listening right now a network or a
network if you're a network that's
listening right now yeah and you want
the smoke
come get it dude come get it literally
anyone this is an open invitation to get
your [ __ ] [ __ ] smacked yeah
in bowling and our team is what i say
our team's name is going to be three
fingers deep yeah yeah yeah something
with fingering three fingers deep so
yeah if you want to get three fingered
by uh us
yeah yeah
come get it like like if you
are an executive at hbo and you and some
of your boys think you're good at
bowling pull up
pull up dog
we'll see we're trying to um
permanently damage any potential
relationships we could build yeah by
smoking the [ __ ] out of people
like that like you're gonna show up
thinking it's like a friendly no we want
it to get ugly like and personal too
yeah when you start that's why your wife
left you yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah because of that shot right there
pathetic hey buddy uh
your wife says the same [ __ ] huh don't
know how to hit it right
that's you
look at you
gutter [ __ ]
you look like [ __ ] you're balding
[Laughter]
you shouldn't talk about what you say in
the mirror
[Laughter]
going home i'm going on i'm using that
bald is beautiful i'm using that [ __ ] i
can't wait till your your hairline is
back to your eyebrows
just rehabilitated earplugs like too
many yeah too deep
yeah have literally
a quarter inch between your hairline and
your eyebrows it's been a year breaking
thank you everyone for your thank you
also listening to all of our you know
passionate speeches about surfing and
cars racing more cars fighting yeah
yeah
it's been a fun year where do you think
we'll net out with spotify um
like ranking wise yeah did they tell you
at the end of the year they should have
already told us right yeah i think we're
going to be number one
i think we are number one
i think joe's out
joe rogan yeah oh you think we're gonna
like we're gonna be number one in those
states
yeah
yeah joe's out yeah we're like literally
huge in every country yeah
if we go to like i don't know touchdown
anywhere zanzibar yeah i guess the the
medieval guy is really good
yeah next year i think we have to kill a
seal on the yeah i think you have to rip
a lobster in half yeah you should take
the pod underwater
oh
i kind of like that yeah
we go we find a planet and go
subterranean yes here i think we should
do that i'm into that dude yeah this
ship can do that yeah yeah we can hide
in the water when things get dicey yeah
we're not going to joke about poop
next year no vomit hot vomit okay guys
what if we actually throw up live on the
show and then freeze it and eat it like
a popsicle
just one lick at a time
you